we just feel very blessed and very very
happy
yeah they do because catherine
schwarzenegger is ready to pop and hubby
chris pratt is kind of grateful it
didn't go down on their hiking trail
that's what happens yeah let's break it
down
on saturday chris posted this photo of
the couple getting in some
exercise before the baby arrives and
hello
cute baby bump alert oh 100 the actor
wrote
ready to pop still don't stop top of the
mountain today
kind of grateful it didn't go down on
the trail though to be real
yeah us to pratt us too i'm very happy
in all areas of my life and i feel
really blessed and really lucky
the mom-to-be is due any day now in
addition to staying active
outdoors catherine has been keeping busy
around the house before she gives birth
she's not an average woman in july the
30 year old author told
et that she's been doing a lot of
organizing
right up my alley cleaning up her
refrigerator and pantry
has kept her calm during this crazy time
catherine has also been surrounding
herself with loved ones and staying
connected on social media
we're in the honeymoon phase it feels
really good and we just feel really
happy
as far as katherine and chris they love
to have fun in the kitchen together
she bakes while the actor handles the
cooking
catherine admits she isn't the most
experienced when it comes to cooking but
chris has been teaching her a lot
i still have a lot to learn the
mother-to-be says quote
it's been really fun it's like a silver
lining to be able to get more experience
in the kitchen
and also to be able to spend time with
your loved ones in this quarantine
so it's been a fun part of it i'm very
involved he's very involved so
it's a great combination of everything
and just really exciting and fun time